[__] bosses piss me off bosses get
employees and as if like they're there
to serve them it's [__] crazy the
entitlement by small business owners and
managers is obnoxious these are fellow
human beings you have people that own
companies that I expect my people to
work the way I work I'm like are you
giving them the same money the [__] are
you talking about I've never even
remotely crossed my mind in my 25 years
that anyone should even work as hard as
me they work for me I work for them but
I'm getting different economics of
course they should not work like the
delusion the biggest mistake people make
and why they can't build scalable
businesses is they have selfish
expectations of their employees